well the US is not making much progress
in lowering the Corona virus numbers
this week 25 States reported more cases
than the previous week on Friday more
than 54,000 new cases were reported
that's the most in a single day since
mid August there are now more than 7.3
million known infections in the US the
death toll has climbed to more than
208,000 here to discuss uh the president
and more is CBS News contributor Dr
David Aus good morning
doc yeah reports are that President
Trump is experiencing mild symptoms uh
low-grade fever and and a cough what
will his treatment at at Walter Reed
look
like you know when he started and tested
positive and started to have mild
symptoms the first thing they did was
they gave him an experimental drug a
cocktail so two different monoclonal
antibodies mixed together so they were
taking from a patient that had gotten
better and they were basically cloned
and grown up as a drug and administered
to him so he could fight the virus they
would bind the spike protein and block
the virus from getting in the cell and
then yesterday evening he started a
daily course of REM dise another
intervenous uh uh antiviral medicine as
well as what we call supportive care
make sure he has enough fluids and make
sure all the numbers are correct as they
follow him in the hospital so the
president's 74 years old uh he is
technically obese how does that affect
dur to not only his treatment but his
prognosis you know both of those are
certainly risk factors although his
biggest risk factor is being male being
male is the biggest risk factor of all
of them but they certainly put him at a
higher risk for complications of Co 19
which is why I think they're doing very
aggressive therapy antiviral and the uh
monocon antibodies to block the virus
you know uh uh former vice president uh
Joe Biden was what 10 feet away from uh
the president uh also Chris Wallace uh
uh closer to him than the audience
members but how concerned should people
be about or doctors we should say about
Joe Biden and his risk to uh Corona
virus you know there's always risk I
mean you can never bring risk to zero
especially when someone has the virus
what we do know is that on Tuesday they
were all the day of the debate they were
all tested which a probe went to their
nose and there was no virus there by a
very sensitive test that doesn't mean
they didn't have the virus but it
probably means they weren't infectious
so I'm not as worried about Joe Biden I
mean obviously the problem with this
virus is it doesn't discriminate and so
if you get enough particles you will get
sick no matter who you
are yeah know a lot of people are
questioning this contact tracing the
president is around a whole lot of
people has been in the past uh and
exposure certainly is is where everyone
is looking right now how important uh is
it going to be to follow that that line
of contact
tracing well well critical I mean
obviously we've seen a number of cases
now within staff in the White House and
outside the White House and you know
they're actually going back to video and
you say who did the president interact
with at close distance for a long period
of time without a mask those peoples
need to be put into quarantine as part
of the contact tracing program and test
it on a regular basis otherwise they can
go out and potentially be asymptomatic
and continue to spread the virus if you
want to stop at cold you have to contact
trace and you have to act on that data
all right Dr David agus thank you